et là je suis maire de la commune
d'accord je t'emmerde on t'emmerde c'est
une vidéo tournée dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi le maire de tresques
l'un en côte d'or est pris à partie par
un habitant la situation dérape une
agression violente qui s'est déroulée
ici à la sortie de ce village de 500
habitants
pour des raisons encore inconnues et
selon nos informations c'est l'ancien
maire qui en serait l'auteur au
lendemain des faits la violence des
coups se lit encore sur le visage de
l'édile les traces apparaissent mais bon
il ya aussi derrière enfin possiblement
à un traumatisme psychologique
et c'est aussi une lassitude d'attitude
parce que cette situation elle peut être
récurrente fait régulier se retrouver
face à des avis ddv du qu'ils soient
habitants ou non qui sont plus en plus
agressif avec les forces de l'ordre ou
avec les élus selon le parquet ce n'est
pas parce que sébastien sordet les
maires qu'il a été agressé
mais il l'a été dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions
alors pour ce représentant des lui cette
situation révèle un problème plus
profond en france en 2010 8 361 maires
ou adjoints ont subi des violences ou
moi si ça peut libérer la parole ce sera
déjà très bien parce que ce qui se passe
ici
malheureusement on a des collègues
qu'ils ont subies n'ont pas fait savoir
dans le village beaucoup d'habitants
sont choqués par la nouvelle
sébastien c'est un maire qui est très
humain et cas beaucoup de relationnel et
vient de traverser une période avec le
coronavirus qui a été sensible
le maire a été à l'écouté disponible ya
plein de choses qui sont mises en place
je pense que la moindre des choses c'est
de lui rendre un petit peu la monnaie de
sa pièce est pas réagir de cette manière
là peu importe le contexte est la raison
pour laquelle ça a été fait le maire de
la commune a porté plainte
quant à l'agresseur présumé il a été
interpellé puis placé en garde à vue il
sera convoqué au tribunal pour violences
sur une personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique